so vinnie i'm curious is there any super
memorable vin moment from a previous
fast film that you leaned on to help you
put that character into focus oh yeah
yeah no for sure it was it was um
the scene from
from the first one where he's talking to
brian
they're in his garage and they're
talking about uh
i could almost
almost word for it uh
he's talking almost exactly about what
we see at the start of f9 you know his
dad's in the last uh on the last lap of
of the circuit um
someone clips him he goes into the side
he pretty much just
breaks it all down and so that's kind of
exactly what i went off there that was a
big inspiration for me
so it's not easy to step into a role
where in vin's first appearance he he
wasn't that much older than you i feel
like it's a lot of pressure on you so
where do you draw the line between you
know falling into doing an impression of
him versus embodying in the embodying
the character in a way that feels true
to you yeah well that was the that was
the um
that was
you know
one of the funnest parts of the
challenge was kind of trying to um you
know like you said
really try to nail his mannerisms but at
the same time kind of bring
my own kind of spin onto it and make him
feel um
real and not just a not just an
impression or or something um
yeah which was hard but um
yeah it was it was really enjoyable
you pull it off so well i'm not just
saying it because i talked to you i was
so struck by that portion of the movie
thank you so jd we were just saying how
much material vinnie has to work with
you've got
next to nothing as far as references to
their father so what are the earliest
conversations that you have with the
team in order to kind of build that
foundation and really understand what
you need to do in order to inform the
other the eight other movies that exist
to that point you know really the only
thing that i had going into it was when
i had a meeting with the producers
they were talking about this first scene
and me being in the car and pretty much
i like they weren't really going to see
my face just my eyes
so it's going to be like some eye acting
there yeah
and then when i saw like the other part
that i was in the flashback i just you
know what ultimately i felt this huge
responsibility to the fans because i
know that
jack hasn't really been touched on
so in one aspect it's like this blank
slate
that i get to create and on the other
hand it's like
i mean it better be powerful because
yeah because it really sets everything
else in motion so i just took what i
took from it was
um which you you find in the dialogue
was that he was really trying to teach
his son
um
how to be honorable and how to how to
how to own his manhood in a way um and
and i think that parents sometimes do
that in a way that they couldn't for
themselves so it's like passing on
something that you would want them to
learn
um and and i think that that's where
jack's struggle was like obviously
there's a lot of stuff in his back story
with the racing and what he was doing on
the street that kind of got him in that
mess in the first place
so um
you just tell the truth you know there's
so many questions that would be very
natural follow-ups to that but instead
i'm going to go back to i acting what is
it what is a tip or trick you would give
someone out there who is doing eye
acting for the first time you know a
director once told me
um
he said
he he said it's in your eyes and not
just like not just for me but like in
terms of
believing in something what's in your
eyes and he said
i have to as a director when i see your
eyes i have to believe it
and what i take from that is that well
if i don't believe it how can i expect
you to believe it
so i just make sure that
i'm coming from a place of truth
and then understanding the camera and
that's it's a visual medium
and so like maybe i'll do like this
i don't know what that was but
i was really going with it i thought i
was like wow this is going somewhere
really good
um no you just you just be
honest and
make sure your intention is is um is
strong
going back to something that you were
hinting at before about like the truth
in the words i want to get this line
right but you basically set up the core
of the entire franchise and all the
movies that came before yours with
just like family dumb you build it right
you take care of it and it will live on
beyond you i mean do you when you're
doing that scene and delivering that
particular line are you thinking about
the weight and how that's going to
impact this entire franchise
absolutely i mean it's it's um
especially when you get dialogue like
that and you know what it means
and how important it is like you gotta
believe it
you have to you know i'd be doing such a
disservice if i just said it you know so
for me what i take from it is just
what i believe is the truth that it it
takes
you got to believe in what you're doing
you have to
if you're if you don't believe in it and
you're not emotionally connected to it
it's going to fall apart and then it
there's so much like
it takes a lot to build something and
you can destroy it so easily in just a
moment
so
so then like the more you're building
something the more important it becomes
and um
and so yeah i i really took
pride in in that and i felt like i was
really giving it to my son
um even though my son's probably like a
man
you should take pride in it it was a
moment that you know stopped me dead in
my tracks and kind of made me go like
like whoa this is it this is where it
all came from yeah thank you um i love
talking about the value of a film cast
and crew feeling like family and you
have the benefit of having a tv family
so with mayans mc and then going over to
fast
do you find that there's any shared
traits among the greats as far as cast
and crews that feel like family and
maybe is there any you know specific
asset of each that you notice that makes
them different and just purely unique to
those that series in this franchise
yeah you know every every um i mean you
can easily just sort of dismiss it and
just say well cruise crew and cass is
cast and job's a job um
but you know with something like mayans
it's it's it's we're building that
together you know and so we all have to
be united
in our goal in our intention and what
the bigger picture is
when you jump onto something as big as
fast it's like that family has been
established the crew everybody knows it
knows each other so
i really went into it as as in um
how can i
serve this family
and for me the crew always comes first
they're the first ones there they're the
last ones to leave
so i i put them first i put their needs
first and then how can i
help the cast because that's for me
that's kind of like what acting is like
i i come with everything that i need to
come with but if i can't pull it out of
in then i'm
you know it can be somebody else you
know like i my responsibility is to
give him something
uh to work off of so i really think it's
it's about service families about
serving each other
all right i'm getting the wrap up i have
so many more but i'm getting picked down
i'm sorry did i take everything oh my
god no those are great answers i
appreciate your time and huge
congratulations thank you